spring and Brandel Chamblee former pro
golfer on tour and golf channel analyst
it almost feels like he's being defiant
there Brandel what bothered you the most
about Rory well saying essentially that
it doesn't matter that golf in the
Olympics doesn't matter I think that's
obviously a strong and different tone
than he took when he initially said he
wasn't gonna play in the Olympics II
cited Zika which is understandable I had
no problem with any of these golfers or
other athletes choosing not to go to the
Olympics based upon health concerns but
for him to say he wasn't going to watch
because they don't matter is an insult
to everybody who is going to the
Olympics who certainly does think they
matter is giving them their time and
interest and all of the people that
worked tirelessly for the betterment of
golf and its inclusion into the Olympics
you know as I said last night golf
suffers from a lot of different stigmas
and some of them are true golf is
expensive it's exclusionary it's too
slow it's hard to understand the rules
and a lot of people will argue and I've
been in a few of these arguments the
golfers aren't really athletes and here
was the opportunity for and if you look
at Rory he certainly looks like an
athlete
Adam Scott Jason Day these guys look
like athletes to me they could stand
toe-to-toe with the world's best
athletes and and do the game some good I
I was I was shocked I think that Rory
will regret those comments for the rest
of his life
Jordan speith no criticism they're
surprised uh well no not at all again I
don't have any criticisms on the players
choosing not to go to the Olympics based
on health concerns I I thought Rory
or excuse me Jordan was brilliant in the
press conference he diffused a pretty
darn tense moment or two with some
levity
but then said and was careful to say I
did not say just a Zika there were other
health concerns that obviously were
weighing on him he he sounded like he
was alluding to something much deeper
much more of a concern to him and you
know all you got to do is just google
the Zika virus and read it and the World
Health Organization puts it on the same
level as Ebola some doctors call it a
pandemic and progress all you have to do
is just read a little bit of it and it
might raise your eyebrows a little bit
against competing down there the other
thing that Rory said that it got lost in
this headline about not going to the
Olympics is he was talking about drug
testing and he said that he could use
HDH and probably get away with it now
wait what is he getting on here well
what I what I you know and again reading
between the lines here he initially said
he was not going to go to the Olympics
because of Zika and we live in such a
caustic world when everybody can get at
you through Twitter and other social
media outlets everybody the lowest
common denominator of society can get at
you and can say disgusting things to you
and make accusations towards him that I
would believe would be completely
unfounded perhaps he saw people accusing
him of not being able to pass the drug
test and perhaps he was upset by the
fact that the PGA Tour doesn't do the
same drug testing that water does and if
they had in fact done that then he would
have already been exonerated from all of
these things that people could accuse
him of doing just by the fact that he's
not going to the Olympics puts him and
subjects him to criticism that in my
opinion is unfair but given given the
scandals that the world of sport has
been through over the last 15 or 20
years you know it's the world they live
it they're gonna have to face them if
there's any if there is any lack of
transparency the war
we'll assume that perhaps there are some
underhanded dealings going on wait you
think that Rory is saying or that he's
responding to people saying you're not
going to the Olympics because you don't
want to do a blood test where HTH would
be picked up instead of in a urine test
I think it's possible I don't I don't
know that to be true but when I was
reading his remarks I'm not going
because of Zika and then I heard him say
something along the lines of yes well no
he said I'm not gonna watch the sports
it matter it's usually saying it doesn't
matter to me that that's kick back at
criticism that's the way I viewed that
and now that nobody likes to be
criticized but golfers I think are
particularly the most sensitive of
athletes they've never ever been
criticized like every other athletes
been criticized in every other sport
athletes golfers don't answer to anybody
they don't have a coach to tell them
what's doing manager doesn't tell him
what to do PGA Tour acquiesce is to
everything they demand the media
acquiesce is they don't get criticized
so they're very sensitive to it I
thought that was more along the lines
the way I looked at it was kicked back
to criticism that he felt like and I
believe if I believe as well that
criticism would have been unjustified
it's enough for me that he didn't want
to go because of the Zika I get that
that would be enough for me that'd be
enough for Jordan I think even though he
said don't put those words in my mouth
health concerns would be enough for me
yeah but the fact is he didn't clear it
up why the did wide a change of opinion
why the change of attitude because there
certainly was a different attitude
between rori choosing not to play
because of Zika and then saying
essentially that it doesn't matter
should golf be in the Olympics prandtl
yeah I mean should it be in the Olympics
you know I every four years I find out
who the fastest swimmer is I find out
who can jump the highest and run the
fast I don't need somebody to tell me
who the best golfer is I know it every
single week I know who the best golfer
in the world is and anybody with a scant
amount of interesting golf knows who the
best golfer is so not
like other sports need it no but when
you consider that because golf's
inclusion in the Olympics and and I was
just talking to Paul McGinley about this
last night governments now give money to
golf programs all over the world he's
involved in one in Ghana and golf was
never on their radar list and now the
government gives money to support junior
golf programs well okay maybe I'm a
little biased but I think Golf is a
terrific way to grow up I think it's a
terrific way to grow up
as I just got hit in the groin by David
Feherty trying to talk a little hard to
concentrate when he's around but it's a
terrific way to grow up
it's a sport for life tell Feherty to
dry it before we've got to be fifty
years too late nowadays but I'll pass it
along all right as I get off okay all
right now we know who the favorites are
for the open I I might surprise you with
who is going to win the open this year
well surprise me lay it on me I've got
to pick a couple of dark horses so maybe
I'll steal yours Lee Westwood is going
to win the open and finally break
through and win a major well okay I you
know I hope you're right I said Lee
Westwood at the US Open on Friday after
he was doing so well he would be one of
if not the most popular winner in the
game that would be one of the greatest
Sunday night press conferences you'd
ever see we laughed we cried it would be
fabulous I hope you're right then and I
would like to choose him as a dark horse
but I have a feeling I'd get shot down
on the set tonight because everybody say
he doesn't really qualify as a dark lone
who darn good okay but what I hope
you're right and he's not far off my
radar at all you know
Sergio Garcia is another one of those
guys who's had so much heartache but is
playing so well just like Lee Westwood
either one of those guys to me could pop
up and when I should have Sergio last
night he's hard to overlook but he
hard to pick you know he's really hard
to pick you know this this particular
venue is known for a couple of major
upset Todd Hamilton major upset
obviously the very first one going way
way way back
Gabby Walter Hagen by a shot Walter
Hagen was a golfing God nobody had ever
heard of Arthur have us beyond that this
golf course is known for picking the
best players not only the best players
but the best players at the height of
their career so I think we're going to
get more along the lines of that it's
very important to find the fairways here
very important to find the fairways
because these are the smallest greens
and the open rotation so we're going to
get the cream of the crop I do believe
and it's going to boil down to the best
players in the world and it wouldn't
surprise me if Dustin Johnson did with
Dustin Johnson it has been doing putting
is not a huge deal here you know there's
a couple of things that are interesting
to me 12 years ago the last time they
played the open here well there's a lot
that has gone on in golf technology wise
and body wise in the last 12 years
so this golf course doesn't have a par 4
on it over four hundred 23 yards on the
front nine so this golf course is going
to get beat up by the best players in
the world I have a feeling Randle keep
stirring it up and retaliate with
Feherty there thank you thanks for that
thanks for that dark pit yeah I'll try
and I'll try it tried it out tonight hey
get in there Thank You Brandel Randall
Randall Chamblee the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience